hello everyone and welcome back to some
rapid action un leaches and also just to
remind you today we will host a nice
simultaneous exhibition with Tesa fuja
he will be taking on some 20
participants of the or rather best
improvers from our improve app and they
will try to see if they have improved
sufficiently uh to uh tackle a player as
strong as him it's not going to be easy
since he's currently number five in the
world I believe but should make it very
interesting uh just to see uh how much
they've improved if you still haven't
tried the app do try it first link in
the description below and also with the
latest update I know a lot of you have
been having issues with uh only being
able to register via a uh uh phone
number now you can also register via
email so if that was a a problem for you
we've uh fixed that so you know give it
a shot first link in the description
below so let's check it out we're going
to go for a nice rapid game uh and see
if um I can play a little bit better
than the prev previous game okay let me
just uh take out the the Zen mode uh so
we can see who we are playing I usually
don't uh as I prefer to only check out
who I'm playing after the game uh but as
this is now a video let's check it out
we're playing against the pun copen
rated 2221 and he goes for theti okay
we're going to go uh
symmetrical and see what happens never
really done any okay so he switches up
to D4 uh we're going to go for some
standard stuff here okay let's play E6
and then we're going to decide uh if
he's going to be a bishop to F4 okay so
he goes for uh he goes for C4 probably
G3 is coming so we'll see how to how to
tackle
that all right so let's go Queen
E7 sometimes I like to play A5 sometimes
I like to play Queen to E7 uh it's
basically if I if I lose a game with A5
then I switch to Queen E7 if I lose a
game with Queen D7 then I switch back to
A5
uh so we'll see if uh if that uh that
works and uh yeah probably he will F to
the light Square Bishop but uh you never
know it's also a very annoying move you
know you're developing your queen very
early on and it's not not a problem like
if he trades the queen can't really be
harassed on B4 that
much I'm I'm
hoping and he uh he does seem to be
wasting some time okay so Queen to B3 hm
now we could go for Knight to C6 that's
always a useful move if I want my knight
on C6 or do I want to play something
like D6 and then bring my knight to D7
so that's uh what I have to decide do I
want to play A5 now does he want to go
A3 next those are some of the questions
so uh D5 not really an issue for
me yeah let's go A5
now
not really sure about Knight to
C6 okay so we started burning a lot of
time even though it's only like move
five uh but what are you going to
do that's the the beauty of Rapid chest
you have all the time in the world so I
want to I want to C Castle my king
obviously once he decides what to do
here probably he will do nothing he will
probably try okay I did not expect him
to capture I'm going to capture with the
pawn simply to get a semiopen aile for
my rook and uh like C5 I don't see that
being a move then Knight to C6 just
lands very
nicely um he doesn't have E4 so he can
play it slowly with E3 or he can prepare
Pawn to E4 with something like yeah he
can to do this he can go Knight here uh
but then we can even consider D5 right
away I don't know uh like I said I'm not
an uh you know I'm far from an expert on
openings I'm just uh trying my best as
it
goes uh uh but yeah I have I have done
some uh work on on some openings uh
during the the past week uh as you've
probably noticed I haven't been
uploading any of my rapid games uh but I
don't think I've uh I've done a lot on
this particular
theme so we'll see but okay our opponent
obviously taking this very seriously
taking a lot of time to to decide
because basically the game will be
decided it's probably not going to be
decided via tactic or via you know
flagging in the end game uh how you what
kind of a position you get at this point
in the game will mean you know how how
much you will struggle later on so what
does he want okay it's a pretty standard
idea the Knight always comes to E5 so uh
I'm just going to ask the question what
if I kick it away he goes here a double
attack on the the pawn and then my queen
no longer is defending so that's a
that's a pretty nice way of handling
things and if I play like uh maybe D6
Knight D3 and C5 looks very
ugly uh because I'm going to have a if
he trades I'm going to have a backwards
Pawn here but I think it can be done so
okay I'm going to ask
him I'm going to ask what is
this and he can he can prove that that
it's okay
okay so I already like my position quite
more than I thought I
would uh especially if I can maybe
develop my pieces a little bit like the
bishop might even have some uh this
would even trap the queen so he has to
be very careful about this like if if if
he goes for something like G3 then
Bishop D7 sort of stops Bishop G2
because his Queen would hang and then I
would get a free tempo for uh um getting
the bishop all the way to C6 so he has
to figure this
out probably he will not play G3
probably E3 and then I still go Bishop
to D7 just to be
annoying yeah I I I don't know I like
this but uh okay so he does go E3 uh
obviously so let's just uh play this uh
because why not he might trade once yeah
okay we we can play it
so it's not really something that he
should be worried about but I get a I
get a free move
in unless I'm missing something uh
obvious okay so of course A4 A4 why not
do I like A4 uh it's sort of
uh it's sort of a permanent weakness
here huh
all right let's
uh I'm kind of not interested in freeing
up his pieces because here the Knight is
very nicely controlled and okay he can
advance it to A5 but it's just going to
be a weakness so I'm just going to
Castle here I don't
think I should force something like
Knight to E4 because okay it could be
that but even Bishop to C6 like could be
played I don't have to rush castling
then it kind of prevents Bishop to E2
because the G2 Pawn would
but he might go for something crazy like
sacrifice the G2 Pawn uh yeah let's
let's play it and see see what he
does like if his if his A4 plan isn't
all that spectacular then I just got a
beautiful diagonal for my light Square
bishop and that's going to be that's
going to be
great so probably he will just uh yeah
if he's not going to go for something
crazy like Bishop E2 and give up the
point Pawn okay so he just uh develops
the Knight he controls E4 okay but I'm
the one who really controls
E4 so no wor is there let's just Castle
now yeah I also yeah I I don't want to
waste a move on castling maybe if I can
threaten some Knight B6 ideas then Force
A5 and then maybe if A5 is played later
on it's going to be a
weakness
huh yeah okay let's let's develop the
Knight probably I don't know I have no
idea okay so he captures once now I can
even capture no I can't capture with the
Knight I thought I could I mean I could
I could capture with the Knight and then
if he captures with the queen I actually
can capture the pawn here but again it
just feels like uh
H it just feels feels like
uh the pawn on B4 that's protected is
really
awesome this Pawn is really weak but I
can play B6 later
on so he might I don't know I'm going to
leave it up to him to calculate uh like
calculating A5 now what if he plays it
it would be just a waste of time even
though I have nothing better to do yeah
okay so he gives up the G2 Pawn that's
probably the best and most active thing
he can do
and um
yeah then the Knight comes here he's
going to have a nice attack uh but I'm
just not buying it I'm just not buying
it yeah okay you can do that you can do
that for sure
uh
huh
that's a little bit
silly oh let's go Bishop
C6 he will take the G7 Pawn
sure sure he
will go
here we can get our Queen into the game
and also if he trades I'm also kind of
threatening the the Trap his Rook
there and if he doesn't do anything I
get my queen into the game so I don't
know okay it's a it's a pawn trade but I
I I like
it he can never Castle Queen side
because this Pawn is
weak so we'll see
yeah I kind of feel my king is a bit
safer than his
King uh something like Rook to G2 even
but that goes under the mask of the of
the bishop so yeah he will have
to move the move the Rook
somewhere yeah the queen
here not the best not the best
definitely okay so he goes after F7
he goes after F7 very
nice okay I did not consider that I have
to okay so what if I go here and he
attacks my knight yeah that's not the
best
h
H yeah I I actually have nothing better
than to give up the H7
Pawn
yeah it's a crazy position and I'm
missing I'm missing a lot of stuff
here does can he actually no he can't
no no so I think that we we we're pretty
happy
now
yeah since he can't really bring more
attackers into the game he could go for
something like Knight to F3 uh I'm
guessing Knight to F3 could even be his
top move or Knight Knight here
maybe Knight here then we get the queen
into the game yeah this Knight should be
really careful either he he should trade
it for this Knight but then the bishop
also defends this or he can't move this
Knight if my queen gets into the game
will'll attack the rook and the F2 Pawn
all right and he's also getting very low
on time so he's deciding whether to
gobble up there that pawn or
not um it's hard to say hard to
say it you know I always okay so he goes
here probably wants to put more pressure
on my knight here so we're just going to
probably
take okay let's
uh
do we want to take let's let's first
consider our options here let's get our
Queen into the game first that's first
and
foremost force him to move the Rook a
little
bit and then we might have some Knight
captures on D2 action with with Bishop
to E4 maybe maybe useful maybe not but
it's for it's up to him to calculate if
it's useful play some else I'll I'll
figure it
out yeah and also if uh if I take yeah
and get the bishop into the game then
I'm no longer attacking A4 so I have to
decide whether I want to I what is this
he goes after my
knight I like it I like it but uh not
too much
okay is he sort of trapping his Bishop
there that's the question I'm going to
say
yes I'm going to say
yes Queen captures of course of course
Queen captures and now how does he deal
with Bishop F3 obviously Rook F4 okay
okay okay so he saw that very nice but
how does he deal with a move like Queen
A3 he has to go here and then we attack
The Rook does he have some funny knight
move yeah okay so here he can go with
the Knight
obviously um
H yeah we're going to keep this keep
this op
[Music]
option let's go E5 E5 looks very strong
E5 looks very strong just take away that
F4 Square from his rook and force him to
calculate yeah and if he goes for
queenside
castles I'm just not buying that not at
all CU then I can capture here I can
play B3 move my Bishop I don't know
something something good should
happen
okay so it's equal material funny
position I I do not okay so B3 so now
what is this is does this just win The
Rook what is this can he defend it yeah
he can move it back to B2 so not really
that useful uh but now we can actually
go for this uh it's uh I don't see a
reply I missed something I don't know I
don't think I have yeah I don't see I
literally don't see a move for him he
cannot uh Castle he can't move the
Knight anywhere yeah E5 probably wasn't
the best but it was uh enough to like
take away counter
playay is there
anything like even even a crazy solution
like
he could try Knight captures on C5 just
for fun and then I capture and then he
checks M checkmates me on
D7 that'd be
funny yeah something I would play that
okay so he tries it but in a different
way he wants me to capture the rook and
then to check made me on D7 yeah that's
the that's the fighting spirit I love it
I love
it okay so he got rid of my he got rid
of my Pawn
um and he got he got away with it but
now yeah I can even sacrifice my queen
here like this is a lot of material for
the queen uh but I don't have to no it's
actually not because he gets the pawn in
and then my knight HS but I can actually
just give a check and uh pick up the the
free rook so now now it's very relevant
with the bishop on
F3 yeah that's very nice uh so do we do
we do what do we do does he have like a
move here or anything I don't think he
does um yeah I don't want to give a
check for no reason or or maybe yeah I
could win the queen with Rook to d8
obviously not win the queen but win
material uh but this is stronger I
believe if he blocks with the queen then
I throw in a rook check and if he goes
back then I have this check and then he
has to block with the queen and then his
Checkmate so this ends the game
all right very
nice okay so he resigns and a lot of
rating points 50 rating points very
nicely done so here what he would have
to do uh there's really no way to
counter this he would have to give up
The Rook uh we can put it on analysis
here yeah he would have to give up The
Rook I would just capture it or doesn't
really matter captures okay here uh the
the agent I should go I should go for
for this but I mean I would since he's
long time I would probably just capture
the queen and pick up the free Bishop
here also uh winning but let's just
quickly go through the game to see what
we could have done better so okay so
okay uh Bishop captures and B2 says that
it's uh you should play it but A5 is
also perfectly fine as you see uh or you
don't see the analysis but you can see
the
evaluation uh yeah captures captures
knight5 says already really bad bad yeah
Knight to E5 says the engine already
close to losing for him and I played it
D6 he went here and I played C5 so it
was a good decision yeah probably
because because of the weird Queen here
he just loses too many Tempe yeah wish I
knew that he plays this I played Bishop
to C6 sort of
E5 uh better Force forcing D5 yeah this
is what the engine wants and then I just
castle and I say okay I have no problems
this game this is just a weak Pawn
okay I went Bishop to C6 still a fine
move Knight here yeah Knight here okay
sort of gives up any any long-term
Advantage Bishop E2 and I went for this
okay still better for me but nothing
spectacular Knight E4 uh he went for
this bishop move yeah and now sort of
Knight captures King captures and queens
side castles uh should be objectively
best as the king is now on the open file
uh I went for Rook f8 okay not the best
gives a question mark but still better
for me so I mean I'm I'm sorry I only
can think in human terms Queen to C2 uh
Queen F6 perfectly fine Rook G4 yeah
okay so now we uh took advantage of this
okay so Queen F5 can also be played yeah
but I thought Queen F5 he can just
defend with Rook
A3 uh but okay I went for E5 uh and he
should have played E4 but then he just
opened up the position completely I
played Bishop to F3 Knight C cap Queen
okay now it's a game over there's no
more here okay I actually there was a
forc Checkmate here Rook captur King oh
there's Queen D1 wow I'm so blind wow uh
probably you guys uh watching this um
were were going crazy but I've seen this
happen actually even in stronger uh
players games uh where you start
calculating a line and you see that it's
winning and then you just go for it you
don't to check if there's a faster
Checkmate because my my brain um thought
about Queen to uh B2 and queen and Rook
to d8 first uh if none of those worked I
would have found Queen to D1 obviously
but here I just wasn't looking for it uh
so yeah uh that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it nicely played by my opponent
but there were a couple of moves too
many that even I could take advantage of
so you know hooray for me and yeah if
you guys have time uh we're going to
start the stream maybe some uh 6 615 6
30 Central European Time and darea will
join us maybe something maybe short of
of 700 p.m. uh and he will start his
simultaneous exhibition against 20 of
our best improvers so we'll see how it
goes I will I will also be live
streaming it with alza and I will try to
you know annoy him as much as possible
to give our people some uh some chances
against him uh so yeah uh once again
really hope you guys enjoyed it and yeah
if you have any favorites from the cter
Masters do use ash suggestion and I will
go over that as I usually do uh so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your
day